two weeks after the 2008 election george
w bush's family gave barack obama's
family a tour of their new home
the white house it was part of a long
american tradition of the outgoing
president's family meeting with the
incoming family
just as the clintons had done for the
bushes eight years before and the bushes
had done for the clintons eight years
before that
it's a symbolic start to the beginning
of the presidential transition
where the current president meets with
the president-elect and importantly
helps the new administration into their
new positions
ensuring a smooth transfer of power
president trump refuses to concede
refusing to begin the transition process
blocking president-elect joe biden from
receiving critical
covet 19 data the presidential
transition usually starts right after
election day in november
and it ends when the new president is
inaugurated in late january
but this year president trump didn't
allow it to start until
three weeks after the election so does
that actually matter
and why does america take so long to
switch presidents
trump is not the first outgoing
president to be uncooperative
in 1932 president herbert hoover lost to
franklin delano roosevelt in a
landslide it was the middle of the great
depression and roosevelt had campaigned
on his new deal ideas
but hoover didn't like those ideas and
used the transition period
to keep fdr from getting started on them
at the time this gap was even longer
the constitution written in the 1700s
had it set at around four months
after fdr's election it was shortened to
the current two and a half months
that's still pretty long but the modern
us with its expansive federal government
has found that time period useful the
federal government is kind of like this
huge massive like big ship that takes a
lot of sort of
direction to steer when the u.s changes
presidents
thousands of federal jobs have to be
changed too
and that changeover takes time those new
hires need offices
government emails and they need to get
fully briefed on the ins and outs of how
these departments run
and most importantly the president needs
to get caught up on national security
and intelligence
and january 20th at noon one
administration is going to take us
over and the threats that america faces
are not necessarily going to respect
that gap
in 2000 the election between george w
bush and al gore
was so close that the winner wasn't
actually decided
until mid-december which meant bush's
transition
had to happen pretty rapidly later after
the september 11th attacks a government
report said
this loss of time hampered the new
administration in its readiness to deal
with national security threats
they suggested that in the future the
transition should start as soon as
possible
but unlike in 2000 the delay in
transition in 2020
wasn't because we didn't know who won
the election nbc news now projects cbs
news projects cnn projects
joseph r biden jr is elected when the
media declares a winner on election
night it feels like a big moment
but it doesn't actually carry any formal
weight
it's a projection the election isn't
officially over
until each state certifies their results
and the electoral college votes in
mid-december
but usually by that point both
presidential candidates have already
acknowledged what the outcome will be
the loser usually concedes and that
sends off this
presidential transition process where
the outgoing administration
helps to usher in the incoming
administration in 2020
we found out what happens when the
outcome is widely agreed upon
but the loser doesn't concede before the
transition can start an office of the
federal government has to give the
go-ahead
the problem is that relies on everyone
agreeing who the
president-elect is eventually after
several key states certified their
results trump didn't concede but he did
allow the transition to begin
without actually referring to biden as
the president-elect
nearly three weeks after the election
the trump administration backed down
president-elect biden getting daily
intelligence briefings on everything
from vaccine distribution
testing and ppe supply chains this gap
between presidents feels long but it is
necessary to keep america's government
running
and for the incoming bide administration
it's going to be a lot shorter
and it shows that our tradition of a
smooth transfer of power
is just that a tradition not a rule
you